so I'm looking around the internet today
and they come across the article that
makes me very happy
since Arnold Schwarzenegger is two terms
as governor are ending he is planning
his return to movies now my first
initial reaction to this was
mentally not verbally I do have
neighbors you see I love Arnold
Schwarzenegger his movies have brought
me immense joy he made one of my
favorite movies of all time predator I
love predator Terminator Terminator -
Kindergarten Cop with wings as Eagles
mmm one of the things he said in the
article which I have linked below in the
description which I found interesting
was that he is planning on taking the
Clint Eastwood route he admitted that he
is older and that he is not able to do
all the things he used to when he was
younger however he can still do some of
things that like say Clint Eastwood has
done Eastwood has been able to take the
same persona his very gritty style and
been able to transfer it into roles that
fit his age and that's what Arnold's
planning on doing and I have confidence
that he can do it I mean he didn't look
good in the Expendables right there's
not a dream up oh no I'm just very happy
to hear this and I wanna know what you
guys think what do you guys think about
armed sports now your return to movies
think it's a good thing like it's a bad
thing you think you still got it
what do you think let me know in the
comments below